au procès villemin dijon en côte d'or
c'est aujourd'hui l'heure du verdict
après six semaines d'audience sept
hommes et cinq femmes se retrouvent
seuls face à leur conscience c'est le
cas de le dire
depuis 11h 33 ce matin le sort de jean
marie villemin se joue à huis clos
dominique verdeilhan vous êtes avec nous
en direct ou en étant oui écouter henry
après les affrontements les
confrontations nous sommes retrouvés
retour
retrouvez pardon ce matin comme au
premier jour de ce procès avec l'émotion
et ce face à la détresse d'un père dans
un silence pesant dans un sanglot qu'il
avait du mal lui-même à maîtriser jean
marie villemin s'est adressé à ses juges
pour une dernière fois
c'est pour grégory que je suis ici leur
at il dit je vous supplie de ne pas me
séparer de christine et nos enfants
assez de souffrance quelques minutes
avant m au garrot s'en était pris
violemment à l'avocat général et à ses
10 ans de réquisition qu'est ce que cela
va apporter à la société disait m au
garrot pour ville ok je comprends pour
jean marie villemin
non m au garrot a plaidé l'acquittement
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure seuls
verdicts de réhabilitation dit il sinon
le doute concernant christ il continuera
à faire son oeuvre
je vous propose d'entendre m garraud qui
a toujours dit qu'il défendrait le
couple villemin
comme ses enfants paris est lié à
christine villemin
c'est le couple ceux qui connaissent
d'affaires depuis le début savent que
dès 1984 puisque j'ai été leur conseil
fin octobre 1984 j'ai toujours dit le
couple même le petit couple et le petit
couple pour moi étaient liés pour le
meilleur et pour le pire
et malheureusement le puits novembre-
c'est ça a été bien souvent le pire mais
j'espère que ce soit avec le verdict
ça sera le meilleur oui dominique ont
assisté un très long procès c'est le cas
de le dire est ce que d'après les
derniers tuyaux d'après les dernières
informations vous pouvez avoir le
délibéré sera long lui aussi écouté
selon les rumeurs comme on dit car
évidemment les
son roi durant leur délibéré on parle
d'un délibéré donc entre deux et trois
heures
d'abord parce que les jurés sont
ensemble depuis sept semaines et qu'on
peut supposer qu'ils ont évoqué ce
dossier tout au long de ces audiences
ensuite parce qu'il faut le rappeler les
jurés n'ont à répondre car trois
questions de ces questions dépend donc
le sort de jean marie villemin
jean marie villemin restera-t-il ou non
en prison ce soir à l'issue de son
verdict et se 9 ans et deux mois jour
pour jour après la mort de grégory
merci dominique verdict des commentaires
bien sûr de votre part ce soir dans le
journal de 20h